I 28 am not happy for my little sister
who's 19 and getting married we don't
have any family left and other than a
distant Uncle who lives across the
country basically we have nobody I've
tried the best to be a role model I
could be for her since we lost our
parents so
young but I feel like I failed my little
sister met this cook at the restaurant
she works at and I don't care what he
does for a living has nothing to do with
that but he's a cook and he's 39
he's 39 years old and just put a ring on
my 19-year-old sister's little
finger I met him once before and I
didn't realize he was that old to be
honest he looks good for his age I know
I didn't think they would end up
together so I didn't think to press on
it she's constantly dating all these men
probably to make up for her severe daddy
issues that I also have but we don't
need to get into
that a lot but I'm allowed cuz I'm 28
so I told her how disgusting it is that
he's an old man and that she wouldn't be
able to live her life who lady to with a
guy like that she left my house crying
and won't answer me it's been 2 weeks am
I the
[__] all right let's just do a quick
answer here yes or no is she be [__]
no that's I'm the same answer huh it's a
no for me I don't think you're an
[__] no you thought I was about to
say yes I thought you be like hey
whatever you me two adults are you high
are you high a lot of people give that
take there's a [__] a lot of we have a
lot of weird subscribers like yo for 40
old am I am I a weirdo like that I'm not
[__] out of here don't try to incate
[__] no you're not no you're not you're
not but your sister she's in love
3919 he be GB I see a bunch of red flags
you you want to go first no go ahead
okay
red flag number one this dudee got a 208
year Gap and like I could forgive an age
Gap if it was like 3050 you know what
I'm saying or 25
45 she [__] 19 my guy
yo yo she been legal for like a year and
a half she could vote for a year she
didn't vote she never voted in her
life that [__] crazy she not even close
to drinking people like well what's a
problem it's like bro how what do you
have to talk to a 19-year-old about at
40 you get what I'm trying to say like
I'm far removed from it so y'all can do
whatever if that's my sister I there's
no way I would accept it not a chance in
hell not a chance in hell it's not just
the age it's like if she's 19 y'all
barely must have known each other for
what a year and a unless you was banging
her while she was underage red flag
y'all didn't have no time together like
you couldn't
have she 19 can I add something to
that if you're 39 but you're not
married and you choose to marry in 19
that's sus to me that is sus to me that
is sus to me yes sir so you've been
through all those times without someone
you feel me yeah and then you find a 30
man and that's the one that you throw
yourself on to marry within a year
exactly that's Su hold up hold up hold
up thinking that we assume we assume
it's within a year we assume he might
have been holler at her before which is
sus so this written sus all over yeah so
yeah you're a cook at
39 don't sound like you got your life
together in the best way possible what's
wrong with being a cook of 39 I was
about to say it depends on the
restaurant I think a 39-year-old cook
marrying a 19-year-old sound a bit sus
to me you know what what
it does there's nothing wrong with a
cook it's not that I ain't got no
problem it's not even the
job yes it is let me take that back yes
it is it is yeah the way she talking it
don't seem like they working at some
upscale spot here's the other thing this
19-year-old girl has pretty much no
family aside from her sister if you're a
grown man who's coming in with good
intentions trying to marry this girl you
would be talking to the sister well
before you pop the question sorry she
has no other family you know there's a
age difference you know this whole
situation look a little funky and you
not talking to the sister before you pop
the question to get at least a blessings
of somebody who has no other family
that's weird to me if you were really
about it in a in a real way I'm saying
that's another red flag to me I here's
the thing I don't think these kinds of
Dynamics have to be bad I think they can
be positive and healthy but there are
certain ways to go about it and honestly
when I see a lot of dudes talk about how
they want a young woman it's just
because they want to have power a lot of
time they want to be able to have
someone who's malleable who looks up to
them like they're the king the greatest
thing cuz they've never had a dime in
their pocket these ladies have nothing
about life right so a lot of these dudes
go for these Dynamics for that reason
now are those Dynamics inherently bad I
don't think so but they can be a
situation where they're right for bad
behavior me personally if I see a
40-year-old man with an 18-year-old wife
you're allowed to do what you want it is
technically legal if that's my sister we
never accept again ever or ever and the
last thing I'll say if that's what my
friends I'm looking at them funky and
I'm probably keep my distance got to be
honest with you that's really weird
Behavior to me yeah or the person as a
young mind meaning uh I don't want to
say the word but it's the word there's
some people that have
um whenever they learn they are behind
or their development is very is stalling
you know what I mean there's people that
are in age and I got some people in my
family like that
like
we the same age but we're not the same
age okay people can always be teenagers
the rest of their Liv I can I in that
instance I could see it and I wouldn't
yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't tell my
sister like yeah that would be the one
that you would be able to marry like to
be honest to be honest I'd be like yeah
no maybe you be the cool dude and
everything and stuff marri and stuff but
you often time wants the the the partner
of your sister to take you like to take
your sister somewhere you know I mean
you're supposed to be a team and build a
team and go somewhere in life not
talling that person you know what I mean
y'all standard sometime is like well
he's not violent he not beating her he
can't yes but he's not taking her
nowhere and I'm not saying that he has
to they're not they cannot go nowhere
together meaning that guy is the
equivalent of a flat tire well why can't
they go anywhere together mentally he's
not there or they cannot they cannot in
life I'm talking about like they they're
not going to be able to uh Quire things
live happily and stuff like that because
he's always going to be like a a ble you
understand what I'm saying no he
ret so he's always going to be something
that's something that's going to keep
her there he's going to stall her a flat
tire oh you don't mean like a literal
[__] no I'm talking no light light
light [__] like I'm not talking about
like CU so is it with a dumb person
could be so the issue is guess she was a
dumb person like there's no upward
Mobility I'm not going to I'm not going
to necessarily depending on what a
person is or what a person is capable of
his capacities of of in life and stuff
like that if that person dates my my my
sister right and that person I see that
that person don't have the capacities to
do a lot in his life to further more I'm
like that's that's maybe not a good
match for you you could definitely do
better cuz right now you're going to be
stalling you're going to be taking care
of that person the rest of your life and
that's not what I want you to do for my
sister so of course I'm going to be
against it I'm going to be like yeah
don't do I can't physically say to my
sister and her but I'm going to be like
I'm not with it you do you you can love
and everything and stuff but that's not
the one that I would be like super happy
or or proud that you're marrying or he's
taking your hand he's he's going to
stall you and you're going to stay at
the same place and that's not the point
of having a a partner having a partner
you want to go places you want to be
able to you know better your life and
stuff like that if that person is not
keep is keeping you from doing that and
you're stallin and you always have to
take care of that person cuz that person
is not responsible is not grown yet
never going to be a full adult I'm not
I'm yeah I'm not going to have it I'm
not going to have it not my
sister and maybe that 39y old is that
type of guy I just but yeah no that 19y
old is going to be B to grow and he's
still going to stay at 19 nope listen n
I'm 33 I can't talk to somebody around
the age of 20 I just can't do
it like them conversations are
dead those are the the deadest
conversations you could ever
have I'm reliving it in my own head
right now see that I feel like dying you
[__]
40 talking to a
19-year-old this girl going out [__]
College Benders you know what I mean bro
doing fres week just oh and they got
little color codes and run into bar to
bar she's still and you should be a dad
at five yeah she's still going to be
she's still going to be a 20year old and
you're going to be pushing
50 nah can't do it oh that's enough
there's so many know now did the sister
handle it the best way with freaking out
on her probably not but can I blame her
no no how who I thought y'all was just
[__] y'all
engaged and I can't get over the fact
that she 19 I mean they didn't know each
other I just can't get over these facts
even the [__] part is weird
the [__] part is weird just the
[__] part is weird so no she's not an
[__] and I can understand
married no dja at 19 that's young young
to be married to another 19y old that's
that's that's enough I would have you
know I would have a little bit of an
issue if a n two 19 year olds would be
married with trying to get married I'll
be like yo take your [__] yo
take your time you can't just be but I
was 19 and 39 and it's not it doesn't
sound better I think a lot a lot of you
guys are going to probably feel
differently and me reading this [__] I'm
like but what's the problem she's legal
Hey listen n listen even if my brother
came to me talking about he marrying a
4-year-old I'm like you stupid if he was
like 19 I tell him the same thing I
don't give a [__] about the gender part
that's just to me that's really [__]
weird yeah all right let's know what you
guys think in the comments you don't
want your bir
[__]